well a man known for his devotion to las  vegas needs our help  you might remember bob crane he's  donated bicycles to children  all across the valley through his  organization called bob's bikes  well last week bob collapsed while  building bikes in his garage  he's now in the hospital he's fighting  heat stroke covered  and pneumonia his daughter spoke with us  about the joy her dad brings to everyone  he really goes above and beyond to help  the kids and  he he's just giving and  kind at heart he's a very good man he's  a great father  a great husband  but he i guess he meets a lot more to  the community  olivia and her family are raising money  for bob's medical expenses and also to  fix the truck that he uses to deliver  those bikes to kids  if you'd like to help we do have a link  to a gofundme on our website at  8newsnow.com